allez c'est parti on y va nouvelle
transition avec l'autre chose pourrait
tant pis
[Musique]
et
salut à tous les gens derrière l'écran
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
mans encore je suis ravi une nouvelle
fois comme toujours de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle vidéo et j'espère que
vous aussi alors il ya quelques temps
j'ai fait une vidéo sur une technique
qui permettait de faire tout un tas de
transition bien cool si vous l'avez pas
vu je vous l'avais dans la description
et bien aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous
faire une vidéo sur une autre technique
qui permet de faire d'autres transitions
hyper stylé et je dis ça je dis rien
mais si vous me suivez sur un stade
vous avez déjà pu voir des petits bouts
de ces transitions en avance parce que
je mets les trucs dans les stories et
tours
moi je dis ça comme ça alors tout comme
dans la première vidéo l'idée ici c'est
de vous montrer une technique qui va
vous permettre de customiser vos
transition et de les décliner au gré de
votre imagination et de votre créativité
pas de plugin rien à installer sa marche
sur final cut mais comme la dernière
fois on va aussi voir comment ça
fonctionne sur première et en bonus à la
fin à ben on verra même une technique
qui marche sur n'importe quel logiciel
et qui est hyper facile et donc sans
plus attendre la technique utilisée dans
l'introduction dans la vidéo vous ai mis
au tout début et bas ce sont des masques
tout simplement l'utilisation de masques
pour créer des transitions alors c'est
pas très compliqué à faire sa demande
un petit peu de temps mais les faits il
est hyper sympa hyper bluffant et puis
surtout vous pouvez le customiser à
loisir sur tout ce que vous voulez dans
vos vidéos c'est donc parti pour trois
transition direction le logiciel de
montage magie alors pour cette première
transition je les pense est un petit peu
en amont cercle et je les ai pensé avant
de l'ajouter est tout simplement j'ai
fait un mouvement de caméra où il y
avait un objet en phase 1 bat ici c'est
un mur et je suis passé avec cet objet
qui traversait le champ donc ici on peut
voir il ya le mur ici qui traverse tout
le champ en dessous j'ai un autre plan
qui est très différent qui est sur un
mouvement différent donc du coup ça
ajoute karine quelque chose en plus donc
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va aller
chercher les faits
masque de tracer ici et on va
l'appliquer
un autre plan alors on va se déplacer
sur la première image ici vous voyez là
on a le début l'idée ça va être de
masquer tout ce qui vient ici après mûre
donc je vais commencer par placer mes
points ob 1 2 3 et 4 et venir cliquez
sur inverser le masque est sûre
l'adoucissement ici je vais venir le
maître ici aux alentours de 20 voilà
pour avoir quelque chose de moins
abrupte et maintenant je vais utiliser d
qui prime c'est à dire des images clés
pour image par image masquer toute la
partie qui est après le main et je vous
la fais en accéléré parce que sinon
c'est un petit peu long quand même donc
j'utilise les flèches ici pour avancer
d'une image et je vais venir déplacer
mon masque ici pour couvrir ce qui
dépasse pareil
et voilà on a notre transition deuxième
transition deuxième méthode cette fois
ci on va pas faire de mouvements de
caméra avec un objet qui va passer dans
le genre on va avoir un plan fixe et on
va faire passer un objet en l'occurrence
billy devant la caméra de façon à ce
qu'il vienne couper le champ aussi je
passe devant la caméra
et si je masquer le plan on a un
deuxième plan ras de sol qui va venir se
caler derrière alors ici on va partir de
11 à partir de là et même opération que
je vous accélère aussi et là ça va être
un petit peu plus compliqué parce que
forcément il ya la jambe donc on va
rajouter un petit peu plus de points de
contrôle pour suivre un peu mieux la
chose
[Musique]
et là on est bon la transition est fait
c'est parfait et juste avant de voir la
troisième et dernière transition je vais
laisser james de la chaîne studio sushi
vous montrer comment ça fonctionne avec
produits salut tout le monde 7e de la
chaîne tci sushi merci françois pour
l'intro maintenant vont avoir les mêmes
manipulations pour faire des masques
mais dans le soft
adobe premiere vous avez vos deux
morceaux de vidéos le premier qui va
être masqué et le second que vous voulez
faire apparaître derrière le masque donc
pour faire ça sous première l'idée là
c'est de repérer la frame où vous allez
faire commencer votre masque donc a
priori c'est celle là donc ce que je
vais faire ici c'est que je vais faire
c'est et je vais faire un cut à ce
niveau là une fois que vous avez fait ce
que vous sélectionnez le bout de vidéo
que vous allez commencer à masquer et
vous allez dans options des faits vous
cliquez sur la plume et ça vous fait
apparaître l'outil masque vous changez
le zoom donc ici on va mettre 20 5%
comme ça on a de la place pour bosser et
comme françois vous commencé à tracer
votre masque en faisant quatre points et
vous cliquez sur inversée une fois que
votre masque et créer masquer la seconde
vidéo comme ça vous avez votre masque de
couleur noire aux premier ou voir ce que
vous faites ou cliqué sur frémit
suivante et vous avancer comme ça ferait
un parfait
ce que je vous conseille de faire c'est
le contour progressif du masque de le
mettre environ à 45 50
ça permettra d'avoir à masquer un peu
moins chat est pareil et sur l'expansion
du masque mettez une valeur d'environ 15
dhafra un masque un peu plus un peu plus
propre
voilà et après une fois que vous avez
fini pourrait faire apparaître la vidéo
que vous souhaitiez faire apparaître
avec le masque et se donnant un
allongement la parole à françois mercy
james
et je vous recommande d'aller voir sa
chaîne elle est vraiment super sympa
studio sushis enfin dernière transition
seul qui est la plus facile à réaliser
et là il ya quasiment rien à faire c'est
celle ci alors pour faire celle ci alors
j'ai rajouté une petite rampe de
vélocité histoire 2 mais j'ai tout
simplement pris un plan où je partais de
mon plan ici un focus surtout manuel
parce que sinon ça l'autofocus trice de
déconner je suis parti avec le plan sur
ce qui était au loin et je suis venu
passer dans un coin sombre contre un mur
le plus proche possible pour couper la
luminosité
ensuite j'ai fait juste linverse je suis
parti d'un coin sombre on est en fait ma
mise au point avant sur ce que je
voulais et mon réglages d'exposition
aussi et je suis allé vers l'extérieur
et mis bout à bout sans aucune
transition ici si ce n'est une petite
robe de vélocité mais c'est pas
obligatoire et bien tout simplement ça
match hop on passe d'un côté à un autre
alors là ce n'était pas un poteau au
final c'était un mur donc j'allais
vraiment de l'autre côté mais on peut
faire ça avec de la téléportation sur
des lieux complètement différent c'est
une transition qui est simple et là pour
le coup c'est le principe du masque sauf
que le masque va être vraiment un objet
du décor un élément du décor et voilà
c'était pas plus compliqué on reparle de
l'autre côté c'est magique magic et
voilà les amis on arrive à la fin de
cette vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à mettre le traditionnel coup 2
blaster sur le pouce en l'air vous
pouvez également vous abonner activer la
cloche partagé leaké commenter tout ça
tout ça va faire du bruit pour qu'on
soit encore plus nombreux et puis moi
comme d'habitude vous d'y rester curieux
et à très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo
moi j'aime bien les gens qui restent
jusqu'à la fin parce que c'est tu c'est
là que tu vois les gens qui sont cools
légende qui avec qui tu partages et tout
et les gens à qui je veux dire que la
semaine prochaine normalement je fais
monter sur paris pour tester des trucs
plutôt cool et ça va le faire c'est je
pense que vous devriez activer la cloche
parce que si c'est pas déjà fait et
avoir des trucs cools ils vont en bateau
se détestent sympa ça